I'm moving for meditation for reading
yes one day if there is a wedding
between this lovely woman and I you will
be invited see what I did there go
what's up baby
this is serge ibaka AKA my physician
welcome to on weiu
so today I will be cooking from coyote
trend and Victor Cruz salsa man I saved
my appetite research but I'm alone
nervous because I know you because about
kuru she is on TV show cars so today I'm
cooking alligator close
[Music]
all right so let's everybody get in
position let's get cameras up short time
like always nice time to will I let go
they're closed ten minute those nails
nice to make things move always a bit
more extra well I don't eat pork and I
don't you red meat so I what could it be
and if it's anything too crazy I
probably won't eat it it's very good boy
Marcus what do you get a close Chinatown
yeah that's pretty easy wow this is a
good name bro but I just hope it's not
like cow testicles I don't know does he
cook that I've been good great I'm a
little nervous
foods here okay which one you prefer
this one or this one this is like myself
this is this is me that's that's you
that's our height difference so how did
you come home being a stylist and model
to a movie I had a very small role in
this horror film and so from there I
just started taking acting classes
working with a coach and then here we
are it's kinda hard on the beginning oh
my god yes I went on a lot of auditions
and was told no no no a million times
and something in my head told me like
don't give up yo you got this big like a
seed we get you in a minute I know
Victor for a long time yes he's into a
fashion too
oh yeah how do you think about my style
what I can change tell me something
about Serge like what do you think I
need to change my style
do you have a designer that you work
with that makes this is awful toward
guys right because I was gonna say I
don't like sometimes
your pants might be a little high new
high low high water issues like your
ankles are showing too much like they're
not long enough no no enough no no Victo
just my guy Victor is here Victor come
on bro oh man yes sir you ain't ready
bring that ass over here what's this my
fuzzy Scheffer pouch
yes sir it's me that's here well how do
you say that muffin emoji Matsuda first
my fuzzy okay Dewey can dance like that
I'm Puerto Rican I grew up dance with
you sometime when you guys go out to
Sasha when I've had enough drinks so you
know I'm waiting for my petition for
reading I'm coming to be invited yeah
I'm asking yes one day if there's a
wedding between this lovely woman and I
you will be invited see what I did there
go tell me a little bit about the movie
shark attack the shark one you look at
it yes
how did that happen that everything CGI
obviously is real and a bit it looks
please well there was a scene in the
movie where they were all standing like
by the beach all right yeah and they
were like man there's no way the trucks
gonna come up here there's no way that
thing came ashore with three heads and
bit like three people and everybody what
am I watching here till there is a
market for fans who love shark related
movies to him I know I mean I think
Chuck movie now yeah five I think so but
it was in the beginning of my career and
it was my first lead role how did I yeah
how did everything start it came through
as an audition through my agents and
then I got the call that I got it and I
was like USP rewrite rushes and that
movie huh oh yeah are you not gonna real
life she's like gonna be alive oh this
is nothing
it comes out on certain occasions yeah
my real life is like right in between
that in between Virginia and being are
you being missing the movie - yeah very
extra mystic stripper killed some people
how do you feel about getting shot and
season two I loved the idea of getting
me shot of getting a shot of me getting
shot yeah and it was cool and I have
like all this blood it's uh we had like
a little stunt that I had to do I
enjoyed getting shot are you better than
football then Victor Victor isn't acting
yeah I would just say yeah yeah
I'll give her that I'll give her that I
mean I haven't had much Nursing yes I
mean I was involved I didn't think the
more host thing then are you trying
walking acting - yeah I've been taking
some acting just trying to you know open
up a different you never don't anger you
never know talked about me doing that a
little bit of everything right what do
you be doing with them I'm at ESPN now
yes can't corresponding things with them
on and I fell live and get up and
first-aid focus more and football right
I've been trying to like talks you know
time to make some bad people of course
I'm always always so I'm just trying to
you know I got to get in with football
first and then convinced them it was
dead okay Victor what do you think about
stress is there a surges a phenomenal
player I mean I've always especially
watched his game evolved over the years
after watching them for many years I
think he's definitely one of the elite
players in the NBA
not just from a shot blocking ability
but he's improved his junk now I'm
getting into endless mode you see what
I'm doing here he's improved his jump
shot yeah can you say something I want
to hurt do we talk when you're in the
SPN like you want topics tell about a
shot at you the Raptors championship
game yeah what so Victor what do you
think about the raptor edition well the
Raptors this year were very impressive
team obviously after adding Kawhi
Leonard it gave them a dimension that
they didn't have before a defensive
player that can go out there and guard
anybody back there and then in the
frontcourt with guys like yourself being
the shot blocking prowess that you have
it's hard for guys to score on teams
like you and you have a solidified point
guard and Kyle Lowry we got a quotation
or getting the ball to you guys yeah see
you
[Applause]
so what is the best meal he cooked for
you
Victor has never cooked for me it makes
some scrambled eggs what you would've oh
I'm buddy but yes I think we're gonna
show the type of boutique-y man that I
was growing up was one that was
surrounded by body quite women right
women yes so they cook for their buddies
wow man that was also the only child for
eight years and the only boy in the
family so I was pretty spoiled but I
make a mean scrambled eggs and pancakes
and french toast and stuff ever had your
pancakes or your french toast I don't
think you made scrambled eggs for me
before it's getting hot is it hot it's
hot here it's are you okay and you do
the nail like the way you'd be doing
your show I could do a little Samsung I
mean I we should've did that I should
have like bedazzled your nails oh yeah
don't worry I want to give you something
to do it it's coming okay okay it's
coming right so now is the fun part
start it's coming oh okay who's here
lovely so yes hungry are you guys
snarling sorry
today I cooked I got the cows
[Music]
what what is this and this makes still
alive in here it no it's not like we
cook that I cook what it just twitched
this is hands and after we done you will
upend the nails
yes no because he got better than me
look see I look but we don't eat that
part anyway we eat please depart
nice so you got a saucier if you guys
won sauce that's a size okay yeah it's
hard look mom nygma no no it's bad it's
good you know all we do to my research
before my guests come here okay so you
see Nick mom look mom there's enough
yeah this is oh I just turned and the
nail did something yes is nice you can't
either like a chicken wing yeah yeah
you want me to shake his hand before no
you got to shake his head why you gonna
sauce again let's go take a big hollow
piece like chicken yeah just try it oh
you see it's not bad it's not bad right
rice is phenomenal
that's why I don't like chicken
sometimes it looks like that you have to
try it and then you can say
[Applause]
it's good now like I said it's I'm doing
they're only alligator stuck in my teeth
you gotta get the perfect amount of
polish so it's not too much this how you
do on your own your show
yeah this the world's first first
alligator manicure and I smooth hey one
other one pink okay and then we gonna do
your nails
I know yeah she did it she's good
thank you
[Applause]
what do you think about next season in
general I'm excited for next season
mainly because there's more parity in
the league now just to see obviously
curry and and Katie and Brooklyn Paul
George and kawaii in LA LeBron and
Anthony Davis with the Lakers Russell
Westbrook and James Harden use it in I
mean the list goes on you know I see the
ship maybe a glass to the chimp you guys
are still the ones to beat
hi your champion to bit yeah all right
Sports Talk
[Music]